Chris Simms a big believer in DK
Metcalfe he want to be a GM so bad if he
was a GM of a team you'd have been gone
in the first 12 picks but he came back
deaf joins us thank you for having me I
mean I don't like why tell me what what
is your assessment know how tough I want
to swear and at the end of the second
round like what's your assessment I mean
I really continued yeah Pete sat me down
when I first got there and he was like I
think teens are scared that I was too
good to be true too good to be true
and you know I kind of believe that but
your brow tree wasn't extensive that's
the crap I one day I got constantly
heard you know I know you had a little
injury concern for people but like some
of the excuses I feel like people were
like trying to find ways to not make you
write the top receiver in the driver you
feel the same way I mean a lot of teams
are scared not scared of me or what I
could do but I thought my feeling spoke
for itself yeah you know I think I ended
up in the perfect spot I think thank the
Seahawks were taking a chance on me and
know God God put me in the perfect
position he did and the other thing too
that helps I think if there is a silver
lining DK because I've seen it with
Michael Thomas for his entire career he
went the second round and that upset him
and that motivated him to prove
everybody wrong and he knows the names
of everybody who was taken in front of
him and he's accomplished more than all
of them combined so I think that long
term there is a positive comes from that
because it lights a fire it maybe if you
were the top five pick you come in with
a different attitude than if you have to
sweat it out through two rounds and that
that worry that concern everything about
that carries you into a great career so
far right Russ told me the exact same
thing because he was going through the
pretty much the same thing coming out of
college how people you know doubted him
and knocked his size and all of that but
you know I think I think it's the best
thing that ever happened to us because
you know we like to compete we like for
people to prove us wrong so you know we
can
set them up yeah okay where what's your
diet why do you look like Superman with
your shirt off like what what is it I
mean you're you are you can you eat
anything and still have a nine pack I
mean what what is it or do you lot watch
what you eat like all your own I watch a
lot you doing during the siege during
the season but after that is it's free
game it's free game and it doesn't
really matter I know you're a freak of
nature you could eat McDonald's three
times a day and you still have a six
pack you would right yeah you look like
you could - no I can and there's a
picture of you right there but you liked
amazing I thought somebody photoshopped
that that's not real yeah I remember you
saying that yeah and it was real and and
it's just and then you go into the room
with Pete Carril Pete Carril drinks you
by taking his shirt off I try to get
Sims to take his shirt off when you came
up on the stage things I want to blind
anybody hasn't seen the Sun in oh it's
been since like this summer
I don't think mighty you don't want to
know I know I wanted to but you you can
make me stay here and work all day I
can't good morning uh football and there
on the beach yeah they had their little
flex off competition out there oh did
they really Wow
they don't I mean you could have
competed competed I would have won with
that know there's a group I know I can
take Mike's off competition it's that
group right there so what do you do this
offseason that you got one year under
you're about how do you get yourself
ready for year to go back look at all
the things I did better what I could
have improved on and focus on that and
you know continue to move forward and
just build on what I when I do my rookie
season what what is it to you and your
game where you like just right now you
said I got to get better at this in your
- I feel like I had too many drops and
you know some of those drops could you
know change the game or you know put me
over a thousand yards or rather some of
that nature but I mean if I if I
eliminate some of the drops and you know
I had a couple of flags
and that's pretty much it pretty much
two drops and you know just study in my
game and seeing how defenses are trying
to take me away your drops are all like
I'm trying to run for yak kind of you
don't have bad hands your drops are
always like I'm trying to snag it and
make a move right it's just a couple
extra concentration right right where
did the mouthpiece come from the binky I
thought you're gonna say that the
strawberry no that is the all-time best
mouthpiece I love it I want to get when
a wife is a fan of you cuz you're your
mouthpiece like she literally like oh is
that the guy with the mouthpiece and I'm
like yeah that's that's him he's yes he
is I mean I think I just try to have fun
right and try to you know that's my
person I like to have fun yeah I'm
childish a little bit so no just show it
off with a little baekje mouthpiece
right with Russell Wilson like just
seems like the most unflappable oh the
game needs to be on my shoulders there's
one minute left like I'm there like what
to you what makes him magical he's
professional first off yeah and like you
said he always wants to game on his
shoulder he wants the ball in the fourth
quarter with a minute left he wants to
be taking us down the field to win the
game I mean I believe that's when he's
at his best is when teams think they
have it's like like a Green Bay team's
thought they they thought they had us
but no we could've came back and won
that game but you know he's just the
ultimate competitor and you know he
doesn't like losing when the play is
over it's not over in his mind he's gone
bowling you know extended play you sense
his calmness like this is it you can
feel it in the huddle in those
situations you do just you just you can
look in his eyes and go oh my gosh she's
not even bothered he tells us he was
like give me your eyes give me your eyes
and then he'll tell is like you know
stay calm
cuz we're just one drive away keep
pushing keep fighting keep eyeing
I mean he's done he motivates everybody
keeps us calm level-headed and I think
that's a great attribute yeah it is hey
DK I'm gonna tell you what I told
Russell when we talked to him yesterday
when it's 4th and 11 3 minutes left
you're on your own 36 and the punt team
comes out I was throwing shoes at the TV
I mean I know you just you've got to do
what you have to do and the coach makes
the decision but
were you confident if the offense stays
out there with Russell Wilson that
quarterback guys like you on the team
that you guys are gonna convert that
keep the ball and don't give it back to
Aaron Rodgers not for sure that was our
only plan of the game in the second half
so right I mean I think I think we
could've did it
especially San Fran game after the San
Fran out thought we could do anything
right yeah all right so 49ers so I give
us your scouting report what's on them I
think you got a run to be able to run
the ball on them right because if you
don't
Nikki B is gonna be in your face right
every play yeah I mean Patrick Mahone's
has Russell Wilson tendencies to me I
mean he can extend the play when he
wants to so it's gonna be a fun game to
watch I can't wait until Sunday yeah
we're gonna make you pick in a minute
can the secondary keep pace with all
those guys Tyree kill Sammy Watkins me
Cole Hardman Travis Kelce DeMarcus
Robinson it just seems like they're
gonna flood that zone and somebody's
gonna get open if they're fast enough to
get past the bb's before their passwords
he is there he's gonna be a long day but
like I said that pass first is unreal
their front seven basically is unreal
yeah Warner came on right Alexander
Korda has been a green lard
yeah well I mean you go on and on with
the names that they have but another
sign of the ball you you also got Travis
Kelce yeah I mean Cole Harmon cheetah
yeah they got weapons is a fun game yeah
so if we can get your pick let's talk
about Nesquik I like the chain he said
like its chain and I think we got I
think we got a little a little Nesquik
oh alright good we're getting all kind
of fries no I what is it it's got a lot
of protein and that's good I see grams
yeah 14 on the field and 14 on the ball
but I mean I've just been drinking this
since a freshman in college man and he's
basically became a part of me
I mean I posted it everywhere my social
media not even before I was even a
partner with them and no they came along
and it was just like a genuine
partnership in my eyes and I love
representing Nesquik and you know hey
strawberry your flavor how strawberry
look like I came to in charge you can't
see I'm such a chocolate guy every time
I'm like I'm gonna drink this because
I'm starving and I like strawberry
shakes but I would be a chopped up guy
just so you know and you're yeah I mean
you check out your Instagram anything
about this you're you're always
shoveling one of these down in your
mouth right oh that's good if I can't
sleep at night I'm going to get one of
these and argue righteously put you to
sleep
damn all right all right we got the face
man now we know okay we've been doing
this all week we take two of your
teammates or coaches or rapper guys from
the Seahawks and we blend them into one
face and you have to tell us who the two
are we have the first one locked and
loaded for DK Metcalfe oh I know what
else Marshawn Lynch a Tyler Lockett is
it MRSA Marshawn Lynch and Tyler Lockett
is that it yes don't yeah that may make
it interesting
thank you you like Russell Crowe in
Gladiator take a take
we don't do that again is that is it
decaying Russell yeah he got it right
all right boom and he is right on it one
more we got one more Wow I think it's I
know what that's just shaking that's not
brother in it it's both of the brothers
together which made chicken like it both
brothers together maybe Mizuki it makes
sense some we've done this week DK where
the mash creates a third person it's
like god that's some third person nobody
I don't know some guy so it was fun you
were the fastest one
so other guys are like they're thinking
and they're not sure you were boom right
on it I um I wanna before we go okay
we're first off I wanted to pick the
damn game okay pick it who are you gonna
pick I can't pick I got homeboys for
both teams and it's gonna be it's gonna
be a fun game okay all right fine and
then I wanna I wanna make muscles with
you all right first I'll feel mine you
think I got something there all right oh
you look fit Tommy I'm I'm fit I'm
bitter my belly just ain't a stick
that's my problem all my fats right here
let me see now come on let me see a big
boy oh man holy crap that's two tennis
balls in there what the Freak that's
insane that's insane
I'm not gonna ask to see your six-pack
right now and get all weird on but
that's pretty impressive
hey DK congratula
Pete Carroll
I've seen him away from football and he
looks every bit a 70 year old man oh
he's a 112 he's faking or something he
gets on a football field and it's like
he's 15 now yeah that's the walk yeah to
in the yeah yeah I mean he's riding
scooters around the facility all day
yeah almost hit me like three times this
year that's crazy-looking way to default
walk out it it
I've never seen a transformation but you
get that guy on a football field
and he loses 50 years like that you know
he's he's amazing play for well a DK
congratulations been amazing to watch
you because we both were on board the DK
met
bandwagon it's great to be right it's
great to be vindicated I'm sure you feel
very vindicated for what you've done
this year and all the best moving
forward the best is yet to come for DK
Metcalf in Seattle see
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports